[Music]
so time then for the press preview we're
taking a first look at tomorrow's front
pages uh it's time to check out those
headlines with whitehall editor of the
financial times sebastian payne and the
sun's deputy political editor kate
ferguson they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight very good
evening to both of you we'll speak in a
moment let's have a look at some of
those front pages for you beginning with
the sun leading on the news that tory
deputy chief whip chris pincher has
resigned and it's the same story on the
front page of the guardian with the
headline tory deputy chief whip resigned
amid sexual misconduct claims
a telegraph also leading on chris
pinch's resignation
pressure amounts on sterling as trade
figures drop to worst level on record is
the headline on the ft
the eye newspaper has an exclusive
theresa may urges johnson to ban trans
conversion therapy story
the teenager jailed for murdering his
five-year-old step-brother logan muangi
features on the front of tomorrow's
metro
now the mirror also leads on that
horrific story with the headline
innocent lost in house of evil
and the daily star reads nurse bernie's
out of bed again referencing bernie
ecclestone's controversial claims that
he'd take a bullet
for vladimir putin
and don't forget by scanning the qr code
you can see on your screen right now you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us and
listen to us discussing them and i'm
joined tonight by sebastian payne and
also kate from the sun good to see you
both again and kate let's start with you
and this exclusive it's on the front of
your paper tori whip quits over drunken
gropes uh and he's written a res nation
letter um after this
uh night of uh well you tell us the
details
i mean this is a kind of bombshell story
which we broke earlier this evening over
at the sun chris pincher the deputy
chief whip has resigned today after
being accused of roping two people last
night at the carlson club the carlton
club is the tory parties for private
members club over in piccadilly it's
where lots of story mp sort of go after
a long day in parliament they unwind
usually away from prying eyes have a few
drinks but what we've found out this
evening is that chris pincher
allegedly assaulted two people at that
club last night he's resigned tonight
writing to the prime minister saying
he's embarrassed himself and others and
that he had too much to drink but
obviously there's a very serious
allegations which is just going to
totally reopen that whole discussion
about
sexual harassment and assault in
parliament and and are the tories once
again going to be seen as the party of
sleaze
yeah sebastian plenty more uh on that
story inside the sun and boris johnson
he's been away uh for uh over a week now
he's coming back from from nato and the
g7 to a whole load of tricky issues and
this one just the latest
well what what what an issue for the
prime minister to come back to and what
a resignation letter as well that if you
look at it on um page seven of kate's
paper great story here it's basically as
dear prime minister i was too drunk last
night that was essentially how he starts
the letter and says that his conduct was
not what was expected and he was
resigning um and it's obviously chris
pinscher not many people will know his
name he became the mp for tamworth and
staffordshire in 2010 and he was a whip
actually under theresa may and he was
forced to quit as assistant which is
number three in the party's party
management operation after allegations
were made by alex story alex story was a
former olympic um athlete and a toy
party candidate he alleged that mr
pincher had acted untowards towards him
so mr pincher resigned there was an
internal tour investigation they cleared
him and he came back a year later to the
whips officers deputy chief whip and now
he's been several ministers he was
europe minister housing minister all
quite low level not the kind of minister
you would see on the broadcast rounds or
making big policy announcements but then
the crucial thing about mr pincher is
earlier this year boris johnson was in
one of yet another spot of bother and
they he need to show up his position
within the tory party and so he called
on mr pinscher who has what good
relations with a widespread number of
tory mps to go back to his old role that
he held a good four years ago as deputy
chief webby took that role to try and
short mr johnson's position and then
he's been forced to quit i think the key
question is going to be can he hold the
tory party whip because obviously we're
knee-deep in a sort of rebooted version
of 1990 sleeves with seemingly every
week something is happening with a tory
mp because this comes off the back of
neil parish the mp for tifton and
honeton who uh had to quit after
watching pornography in the house of
commons and imran ahmed khan the mp for
wakefield who had to quit and has now
gone to prison for child sexual abuse
and it's got the whole ef sleaze about
the toy party again and the general
public i'm sure will look at this and
just think what earth is wrong with tour
mps where do they find these people who
are acting like that yeah kate a story
on the front of the guardian as well um
your paper is saying that the you
understand he won't lose the party whip
that he will be able to stay on as a
backbencher i mean i i suppose uh one
thing in his favor is that he's admitted
this straight away there's not been any
sort of debate about it he's come out
he's apologized he's resigned
to be honest there would be no choice
but to admit it straight away it
happened in a public place there were
plenty of eyewitnesses i think
you know that the world in which this
could possibly have sort of dragged out
with denials is just not the world we're
living in i think sebastian's totally
right the question now is really can he
keep the tory with there'll be plenty of
mps some of whom have already got in
touch with me tonight very unhappy that
he's going to continue to sit on the
tory benches now we've had this before
with other allegations um
which sebastian just went through and
the tory party tend to keep the whip
until or unless a criminal investigation
and charge is brought so it seems that
they're trying to hold that line in this
case too um so as long as there is no
criminal
prosecution that he'll keep the tory
whip and we know from tonight from
number 10 sources they're saying the pm
thinks he's done the right thing he's
fessed up he's decided to resign from
his front bench position but you know
huge huge unhappiness in the party about
this and i think sebastian's right has
the party has there's a danger it's
going to start smelling of sleaze right
and that's just a bad place for the
party to be in and for politics to be in
yeah quick thoughts uh quick final
thought on this sebastian before i ask
you about the latest from ukraine
i just think the fact is that um you
know the toy party needs to get a
serious grip about its cultural and
morality issues amongst its mps at the
moment because as i said it's not just
about misconduct of drunkenness of of of
sexual allegations across the party as
well it all feeds into this culture you
saw in the run-up to the 1997 election
of course when the tour is lost in a
landslide to tony blair where it feels
if the party's got a stench of decline
to it as well and you know john major
very famous did his putable shut up
leadership contest in 1995 for all of
his critics saying look you need to just
get behind me or get rid of me
essentially and i think at the moment
and with these kind of issues about how
mps are behaving and the allegations
around them there needs to be a sort of
a real cathartic moment within the party
and don't forget as well we've got
another tour mp who we are not allowed
to name for legal reasons who's being
investigated again for sexual harassment
there's another thing and of course you
know this is very raw politics for a
moment if we put aside the victims of
this which are obviously the main focus
but if chris pincher is forced to resign
if say there were more allegations
there's no indication of that at the
moment but if there were that's another
by-election and another loss for the
tory party and every time this happens
it just chips away at boris johnson's
authority and which obviously as we know
is in a pretty perilous state at the
moment
okay uh we're going to have to go to a
break and we'll we'll come back to
ukraine in a moment thank you uh for now
coming up bernie ecclestone under fire
for defending vladimir putin i will be
talking about that next
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview still with me sebastian and kate
uh kate let's talk about ukraine russia
has uh had the upper hand really for
some time but there has been a victory
for ukraine in the last 24 hours the
russians have been driven out of this
strategically important island in the
black sea
yeah this is snake island which people
may remember from earlier on in the
conflict when you had those sort of
brave ukrainian troops trying to hold
out against the russian onslaught well
back then we thought that russian
onslaught was going to go on and on and
that the red army tanks would be
you know irrepressible really but here
we go we have the ukrainians getting
that island back i just think that
that's something we're all going to be
celebrating willing them on and it's
sort of a symbolic victory really
because it was such a heroic first stand
that they've driven the russians out i
think is a obviously a great piece of
news for ukraine and also i think all of
the west right when the world's eyes are
on that conflict again looking at
military spending and the role of nato
and the g7 in that
uh yeah let's have a look at the front
of the yorkshire post uh sebastian and
focus a bit on that uh uk defense
spending going to rise to 2.5 percent of
gdp by the end of the decade i mean it's
it's clearly welcome news by ukraine but
is it enough and is it quickly enough
because that's quite a time frame when
they need that money debt and help
desperately now
well the uk has obviously been at the
forefront of sending weapons money
troops support aid political backing
whatever you want you can name it the uk
has been the forefront of it with
ukraine i think in terms of the military
spending uh this is much needed it's
good it's a lot of money 55 billion
pounds by 2030 and obviously ramping up
the uk's defense industry to cope with
that money does take time the only
caveat i would have though is going to
be inflation because inflation is going
to stay and remain high in potentially
double digits that's going to eat into
the uk's capital spend not just defense
but across the whole public realm so the
commitment is great and as with all
these things let's see how exactly it's
going to get delivered well the
commitment is great kate isn't it but
you know the government have been
stripping uh the the
the defense forces
over the last 15 years haven't they
yeah i mean there's probably two things
to say about this money first of all
it's good and welcome that it's
increasing i think all eyes are going to
be on the rest of nato now who have
always struggled to even hit that two
percent target there's talk well they
said today that they were looking to
increase their military spending really
we need nato to follow
but second of all you're totally right
in the background of all this is this
huge row about cuts to troop numbers so
the british army troop numbers is going
to fall to i think it's it's smaller
since the napoleonic wars 200 years ago
so
yes more money is going in but still is
that enough because what this conflict
has taught us is that you can have all
of the cyber tech you like all of the
sort of wizzy drones and things but
actually you do need boots on the ground
if there's an invading force and you
want to repel them that's what
ukrainians have learned and that's what
nato are learning
vicariously through the ukrainian
conflict and ultimately sebastian um the
us
is critical to european security um but
i guess for for too long they've been or
we've been relying on them to to sort of
pick up the bills
this obviously came to the forefront
during donald trump's presidency where
there was a lot of talk and suggestions
he might pull the us out of nato which
of course would have been totally
disastrous for western european security
and at that point france germany the uk
all looked as if they would sort of try
and think of a world where the us wasn't
involved in nato and that never happened
but it's interesting it's taken ukraine
to really see germany shift its stance
on russia and on its own armed forces
and defense spending and as kate was
just saying there will be a lot of
pressure on the european countries to
try and match this and we've also seen
over the past week because obviously
boris johnson's been at the g7 summit at
the nato summit coming back to the uk
tonight after quite a long time away
he's going to have to look at other you
know
about the other threats to other nato
members and i think there's a huge
concern in whitehall about the baltic
countries and depending on how ukraine
plays out where there's going to be
other russian threats and i think that's
the impetus behind this new spending
okay and kate in 20 seconds tell me what
bernie ecclestone's been saying he's put
his foot in it again
benny customs keeps saying things he
should just not bother saying so today i
think he said take a bullet for putin
he's a nice guy the warsaw zelensky's
fault i think his take on the ukrainian
war is a take we probably don't need
yeah okay i'd say his take on everything
is something we don't need read more
about that on the front of the star
sebastian kate thank you both we shall
chat again in a moment right now we're
gonna have a look at the weather